hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to my bones now this is an
indie horror game that came out just a
little bit ago that supposedly has
decent reviews so I'm gonna play it to
see if it's good or not but the
unfortunate thing about these indie
horror games is always like you know I
always play a lot of these games and
their quality is very terminan on whole
bunch of things but this one was
actually on Steam and cost money so I
can assume that there's probably gonna
be some level of quality or else there's
not and it's gonna be hilarious one or
the other one or the other so put on
your thinking caps and open up your
minds a little bit to the possibilities
of what could happen here oh it's like
Star Wars I was just like everyone else
I had a family job friends a puppy a
kitty I was happy to me one day
something happened it felt like I was
possessed by something evil I was
attacked by such a strong anger I
couldn't help it nor could I continue to
capitalize my eyes we live not far from
the village in the woods our family was
not perfect but we were happy I had a
daughter and two sons the mishap
occurred when I was in the woods and
stumbled upon a strange crypt at that
moment I was met by wild anger at that
moment gained to me my wife and nearby
lay the axe then it was all a blur okay
wait so is it called my bones because
wait are you the one that's dead were
you calling your family property how
dare I mean you murdered them so they're
obviously that's obviously bad but I
mean how dare you call your family
property and this what is most likely
the 21st century how dare you
I should probably more like be able to
do so I have no idea what I'm okay I'm
ready come on whoa alright I'm in my own
grave is this why it's called my bones
probably okay look spooky seems to be
like hell reminds me of doom
this is the tomb of my wife wait you
buried her already okay
I loved him better than all I did not
expect that he will go crazy and kill me
with an axe but I love it all smooth oh
I know about that wait I gotta read this
again it didn't make any sense
I loved him better than all I did not
expect that he will go crazy and kill me
with an axe I mean who would but not me
but I love it all smooth but I love it
all smooth what do you love all smooth
yourself your husband your your bones
that makes very little I'm assuming I'm
assuming that this was made by someone
who doesn't speak English as a first
language which I played before I'm not
gonna make fun of him for a grammar but
I can't help it if at last Solaris daddy
why did you kill me honey was fun we
walked near the river when you took me
into his arms whose arms and began to
sink what I love you daddy
I know you didn't didn't what why did
you kill me on it was fun okay i-i'll
edge it Amelie can't understand that
what in the hell did that mean and why
was it slightly funny I don't mean to
laugh I'm trying to take two somewhat
seriously but this game is oh it's
giving me good vibes I'm all about this
is really good oh god damn it cruel
you know nothing cruel what oh hey oh hi
was that an elf
was an elf orc what was that okay
can you stop maybe it's just a bad dream
yeah probably not I'm gonna go with no
on that one
Oh collected key okay I oh this is not a
run-and-gun four keys all over the place
but a probably more could you shut I am
trying to talk you damn crows why don't
we just get out of here for a little bit
if you'll make my way up to this castle
that I proposed a church never mind
Jesus shut up you crows oh man hello
stinky Winky how you doing
it seems this door is broken why don't
see you tore it all yep definitely
broken in that it somehow fell into a
pit of hell and I am left to wander
purgatory for all eternity
oh hello that was this way I need hello
super great
no oh it's a super grade of lagging oh
oh or we're just gonna load the next
level one or the other
err be a little bit appalling me a
little bit of pollen be clip mix it
together you get [ __ ] Aladdin oh oh oh
it's the full motion video I didn't know
this is gonna have animated cutscenes in
it you know I was like something oh
where am i where no where I am NOT where
am i a little fan of will I am if you
know what I'm eating his lesser-known
cousin where I am
legend precedes me whoa
tap-dancing Larry please stop practicing
on the door we need that for stuffing
things order to the keeper you should
immediately go to the barricade and
attempts to stop the monster to break
into the vault once the deal is
completed go back to the church for
future ministry okay if the Beast breaks
through through through the cell which
is not likely I mean why would happen
I'm only three days from retirement and
it's my birthday
and my wife's anniversary then you
should immediately leave the dungeon
with ministers oh boy oh boy oh boy this
had good reviews on Steam I mean it's
got that sort of sense of charm that I
love so much ooh that is bright Hey Dude
how's it going you look look good oh I
didn't mean to read that again excuse me
oh you know came in tap dancing Larry oh
no you broke up Burrell damn it Larry
what have I told you about tap dancing I
know you're trying for the Olympics but
come on we need to keep order in this
ministry place was it tap-dancing Larry
that left me the note I'm so glad this
ladder is going nowhere Arden Bird and
Squiggy got a mouse sorry I can't hear
you over this moaning
tie the moaning suddenly got louder
death awaits all who tread this path oh
boy
I can't wait please okay never mind then
Oh looks like a monster somehow broke
out of that cage wait wait the Beast is
on the loose thank you tap dancing Larry
for writing me that note just in time oh
that looks good I meant oh hey are you
the Beast what oh I love this game
oh I love this game hello
you weren't there before how are you
doing oh boy this is this all the death
that awaits me good that moaning just
just be a little bit quieter I need to
hear my own heartbeat for a little
longer no louder I was going to go with
louder I was hoping it was gonna get
louder oh hey how's it going what ha ha
okay all right - okay cool i'ma leave
now I'm gonna go
oh yeah
yes I thought I got a key didn't I get a
key I thought I got a key so loud Oh
bunker boo oh man my ear holes oh oh
thank you thank you all over here oh oh
oh boy
Oh bunch of words that I don't
understand hmm I don't know what any of
these means especially this one here
what good
Go Go Go do foon don't do Xun I don't
know it's totally a mystery to me in
this one forgetting that I don't mean to
be mean I don't want to be mean I don't
want to be mean but I mean I do want to
be a little mean because this game did
cost money it did it did cause money
I'll reserve my judgment till the very
end so I have no idea Wow okay I entered
the hallway of lag oh no it was the
hallway of loading I forgot that that's
how that happens in this game I'm glad
that my eardrums have down ruptured
since that loud oh hey hello
baby I need to make a choice between
good and evil
do I do I need to make that oh hey well
which one's evil which one's good okay I
want to try the good one I mean the good
one looks so open and inviting and yet
the evil one looks slightly sassy with
its arms raised
oh boy alright okay let's uh let's go
for good let's go for good here I'm
coming baby I can't I can get a second I
didn't read that okay I'm coming baby
how are you doing are you doing baby oh
okay well I guess I won't spend eternity
in the arms of my loving wife who likes
it all smooth oh that's why Oh
we forgive you and give a second chance
oh do you are you back to life now what
oh okay we are in the 21st century
I managed to get out of hell even the
worst person has the right to a second
chance in our life there are moments
when the good becomes bad and bad is
good despite all I will try to change I
want to become good yes it wasn't your
fault that you became evil you literally
said you went to a [ __ ] and then you got
haunted by a spirit that caused you to
be anger what is white oh oh oh that's
the end oh I want to be nice to this
game I really do but there's not a lot
of redeeming qualities about it I mean
it costs two dollars there are games
that are free that I have higher levels
of quality control than this game but
hopefully hopefully you got some
enjoyment out of this video alone
whether or not you go out and buy the
game and then play it for the evil
ending totally up to you spend your
money however you want to but hopefully
this video brought you some enjoyment
because surprisingly I laughed quite a
bit of this game even though I wasn't
supposed to so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
think of this game in the comments down
below
literally don't pull any punches say
you're honest true opinion whatever it
may be and thank you again everybody for
watching check out some more scary games
that I've played some actually like
literally they're more scary in the
description down below or the
annotations over there thanks again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next video breeding but uh I
didn't know what mumble top was player